a new proof has been announced to which
they claim is the largest proof ever it
comes in two parts the first part is
this this is part 1 and part 2 is 200
terabytes large that is huge I'm gonna
start with something simpler something
perhaps you can try yourselves okay this
is the idea let's take the numbers 1 to
9 I'm just going to draw them out in a
grid here I think these are the numbers
1 to 9 I'm not going to write the
numbers in quite yet and now I'm
interested in a plus B equals C so these
are gonna be whole numbers and I'm a I'm
gonna have a plus B or C that's not a
difficult equation I want them to be
different so let's have a less than B
less than C can I color these numbers 1
to 9 using red and blue so that I don't
have a plus B equals C all the same
color so I don't want them to be all red
or orbital that's something I want to
avoid so let's try to see if we can best
start with one it's a red there's no
reason why not and let's have to be at
blue this means 3 is 1 plus 2 that's
okay we can pick a color it could be red
or blue and Brady you could pick if you
want do you want to be red let's make it
red yeah ok fine so we'll have 3 in red
well that's interesting because now we
can make some deductions 3 is red one is
red so four can't be red that's what
we're trying to avoid we don't want them
all to be the same color because then we
would have a plus B equals C all the
same color or one plus three equals four
would all be red that would be something
we're trying to avoid that means 4 it's
going to be blue that's right for as
blue great but that's something we can
use as well 2 is blue for is blue 6 will
have to be red let's put 6 as red well
that's interesting now because we've got
1 plus 6 is 7 we're trying to avoid it
being red will have to be blue let's
make it blue 6 plus 3 those are both
Reds
I'm gonna have nine as blue okay we're
doing okay so far don't have a problem
oh but wait there is a problem because 2
plus 7 is 9 and they're all the same
color oh no III messed up I didn't do it
I failed here this has failed well
there's lots of other ways of coloring
in the numbers 1 to 9 in fact each of
them has two options red or blue so it's
going to be 2 to the power 9 512 so
there's 512 ways new colors in is not
very hard for you to convince yourself
that you're always going to fail you're
always going to end up with something
like that or you could just check all
the options if you want you could check
the 512 options and you'll see and it's
not possible to avoid a plus B equals C
in the same color that's what this
problem was about but they took it one
step further they were interested in a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
and they wants to color in the numbers
using red and blue just like we did
before but they wanted to avoid a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
being the same color so all being red or
all being blue now you might recognize a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
that's Pythagoras theorem but we're
interested in whole number solutions for
this so a solution might be 3 squared
plus 4 squared that is actually equal to
5 squared so we just check and that's
see if that's a solution 3 squared is 9
4 squared is 16 adding together is 25
great because 25 is 5 squared another
solution to this might be 5 squared plus
12 squared equals 13 squared that is
another solution that just uses whole
numbers these are called Pythagorean
triples they're not particularly rare in
fact the ancient Greeks knew how to make
them out I'll show you how to make a pie
triple if you want you just take two
numbers em and and and what you do is a
is the equal to M squared minus N
squared so we're assuming M is the
bigger one B is two M times N and C is M
squared plus N squared and that is a
Pythagorean triple all you have to do is
pick two numbers and you can generate a
Pythagorean triple there's an infinite
number of them absolutely so this is a
well-known thing this is not a mystery
but the mystery now is can we color in
the integers using red and blue so that
we don't get a Pythagorean triple in the
same color so imagine we have a blue set
of numbers and a red set of numbers and
the red set do not contain a Pythagorean
triple and the blue set do not contain a
Pythagorean triple now there's lots of
ways you can color your numbers is there
a way to avoid this problem so this
called the Pythagorean triple problem
now this is an application of something
called Ramsey theory and Ramsey theory
is about finding structure in large
number of objects so if you have a large
number of objects is a structure
unavoidable is it inevitable can you
avoid this problem now the answer is no
you can't avoid it so what these guys
have shown is that this is a solution
that koryn the integers from 1 to 7
thousand 824 so they've split them up
into red numbers blue numbers and you
see the white squares perhaps the white
squares represent numbers that could be
red or blue and it doesn't matter so it
would be a solution either way but when
they took it one step further and they
looked at coloring in the integers from
1 to 7 thousand 825 that's when it
failed that's when they showed that it
can't be done that you're always going
to end up with a Pythagorean triple in
the red set or in the blue set
this number 8 7800 25 is the straw that
broke the camel's back it's the last
item on buckaroo it's the thing that
broke it all down the reason 7000 825
broke the solution is because it's in
two Pythagorean triples here they are
625 squared plus 7800 squared is equal
to seven thousand eight hundred and
twenty-five squared and 5,180 squared
plus five thousand eight hundred and
sixty-five squared is also equal to
seven thousand eight hundred twenty-five
squared so what they found is that when
they looked at the solutions for seven
thousand eight hundred twenty-four you
look at all the possible solutions 625
and seven thousand eight hundred were
always the same color so they were
either let's say they're blue and these
numbers 5,180 and 5865 were always the
same color and the other color they were
always red perhaps in this case which
means seven thousand eight hundred
twenty-five now has to be red and blue
at the same time which is not possible
and the whole thing fails and in the
1980s our friend Ron Graham actually
offered a prize for the person who sold
this problem the Pythagorean triple
problem he offered $100 prize which he
is now delivered to one of the computer
scientists at the University of Texas
he's delivered the check is he's paid up
so to show that this is a solution for
one to seven thousand eight hundred and
twenty four to show that is a solution
and to confirm it's a solution take
seconds on a computer it's not very
difficult to do but to show there are no
solutions for one to seven thousand
eight hundred and twenty five if he
checked every possibility would take a
massive amount of computing time the
number of ways you could fill those in
when each integer as as two options
would be 2 to the power 7 thousand 825
and that number is so massive
well you could take a supercomputer take
too long for a supercomputer to check
imagine all the Samba supercomputers in
the world and imagine them checking all
the possibilities since the dawn of time
since the Big Bang you still won't be
able to check all the possibilities so
that's not what they did what they did
is they use some clever mathematical
tricks to reduce the number of things
they had to check they bored this down
to about a trillion things that they had
to check and that took them about two
days using a supercomputer in the
University of Texas
the only problem really with this type
of proof is it doesn't increase our
understanding of why this is true what
is special about the number seven
thousand eight hundred and twenty five
why why that number these kind of proofs
that require this huge amount of
computation does not tell us anything
about why something is true and there is
a conjecture that this will always be
true no matter how many colors we use we
might use three colors or four colors
now that number is going to get larger
and larger and the amount of computation
it takes to find where it fails it's
gonna be bigger and bigger but to find a
proof that shows it's always true that's
probably going to take traditional
mathematics the great courses plus is an
on-demand video learning service with
expert lecturers from all around the
world covering all sorts of topics from
nuclear physics to Roman history now of
course they've got you covered for
mathematics and this section here on
trending and newsworthy topics is handy
if you want a deeper understanding of
current events and look at this dog
training 101
that's right Audrey it looks like our
weekend is sorted yeah you up with some
dog training 101 now you can join a free
trial with access to all the videos
including the dog training by going to
the great courses plus.com slash
numberphile this is a great chance to
die
deeper into the topics you love and
using the URL or the link in the video
description will show them you came from
numberphile our thanks to the great
courses plus for supporting this video
thank you thank you